The time has finally come: Star Wars: The
Clone Wars is back on our screens, taking
its final turn on Disney+ after spending nearly
six years in the dark.
Here's the first episode of Star Wars: The
Clone Wars' final season explained.
Entitled "The Bad Batch," this episode opens
with an epigraph that reads, "Embrace others
for their differences, for that makes you
whole."
It's then revealed that the rocky planet of
Anaxes, which holds Republic shipyards, is
under attack from Admiral Trench's Separatist
Forces.
A massive tarantula-like being with cybernetic
enhancements, Admiral Trench and his forces
face the "two-pronged assault" that Mace Windu
and Anakin Skywalker lead on the ground and
in the air.
But after weeks of battling, the Republic's
strength begins to fade.
In efforts to break up their string of losses,
the Republic forces take a moment to evaluate
their past mistakes and come up with a new
strategy.
Y'see, enemy forces have been consistently
outsmarting the plans of skilled clone trooper
Captain Rex.
This has left the Clones vulnerable to droid
attacks the more they use any given tactic.
Speaking with Mace and Anakin, Rex theorizes
that the Separatists are using analytics to
predict the Clones' strategy, and because
their counterattacks are so specific, they
must know Rex's playbook.
"The losses we are experiencing on Anaxas
are not commonplace."
"It's my strategy the droids know.
My playbook!"
But that's only part of Rex's theory as to
why the Republic is losing.
As he tells Commander Cody immediately after
their meeting with the Generals, Rex believes
his fallen friend Echo is behind all of this.
Commander Cody insists that it's impossible
for Echo to be alive given that he died at
the Citadel on Lola Sayu when trying to secure
transport and escape enemy forces.
As a reminder, this all happened on season
3, during the 2011 episode "Counterattack."
Captain Rex continues on nonetheless, explaining
that the way the droids are countering the
Republic on Anaxes implies they know his strategies,
which are all battle plans that he and Echo
drew up together.
Though Commander Cody is firm in his belief
that it's impossible Echo is alive, Rex says
that "Echo's fingerprints are all over" the
Separatist strategies.
He posits that Echo has been brainwashed in
some way, forced to hand over to the Separatists
every move the Clones would make.
From there, Rex and Cody round up a small
crew of Clones to lead to the Separatist Cyber
Center and discover the truth behind the situation.
The group is Clone Force 99, better known
as "the Bad Batch," a foursome of mutant clone
troopers comprised of Crosshair, Hunter, Tech,
and Wrecker.
They each have their own quirks Crosshair
isn't "much of a conversationalist" but is
an expert marksman, while Tech could talk
someone's ear off about random facts and form
a tense dynamic with Captain Rex and Commander
Cody, whom they call "regs."
The usual action and intensity ensues as Rex,
Cody, and the Bad Batch face off against a
pack of battle droids and a sea of creepy-crawling
robo-spiders, which leaves Cody wounded.
When that fight is over and a minor spat is
had in the aftermath, the crew agrees to follow
Captain Rex's plan to infiltrate the Cyber
Center.
They soon take hold of an outpost near the
Cyber Center, blasting Separatist droids left
and right as the background music swells.
Admiral Trench states that the Clones must
"know about the algorithm" since there's no
clear advantage to seizing the outpost.
After Tech and Rex make their way into a hub
of the outpost, Tech taps into the Separatists'
computers and analyzes its data per Rex's
instructions.
He locates the particular program Rex mentions
which turns out to not be a program at all,
but instead a live signal originating from
Skako Minor, a planet controlled by the Techno
Union.
An analysis of the audio transmission uncovers
a shocking truth: the individual who sent
it bears the operating number CT-1409, Echo's
number.
The closing moments of Star Wars: The Clone
Wars season 7, episode 1 double down on what's
going on: Echo is alive, and has indeed been
relaying the Clones' tactics to the Separatists.
"That number, Cap.
What did it mean?"
"CT-1409.
That was Echo's number.
He's alive."
Clearly, the biggest aspect of The Clone Wars'
final season premiere that needs unpacking
regards Echo and who he is.
Nicknamed for his ability to follow orders
so well it seemed like he was echoing words
through actions, Echo was a member of the
Domino Squad a clone trooper cadet unit led
by Commanding Officer Hevy and including fellow
Clones Cutup, Droidbait, and the much-loved
Fives.
Stationed on Kamino, where they completed
their Citadel Challenge to graduate into the
Grand Army of the Republic, the Domino Squad
faced tragedy when they moved to Rishi Station
and were tasked, along with Captain Rex, with
protecting the Rishi moon base.
Separatists struck down on them, killing the
majority of the squad.
Only Echo and Fives remained of the Domino
Squad, and the two went on to join the 501st
Legion after Jedi Generals Obi-Wan Kenobi
and Anakin Skywalker commended them for their
bravery and promoted them to the rank of ARC
trooper.
On the Clone Wars season 3 episode "Counterattack,"
Echo and his 501st Legion teammates ventured
to Lola Sayu in efforts to rescue Jedi Master
Even Piell from prison in the Citadel and
obtain from him coordinates to the Nexus hyperspace
route.
Piell died in the midst of the chaos, and
while attempting to escape after the mission
was deemed successful, Echo seemingly died
as well.
The Clone Wars' season 7 premiere doesn't
reveal exactly how the Separatists turned
Echo to the dark side, but some fans may already
know how this particular arc could play out.
Four unfinished Clone Wars episodes surfaced
online many years ago, and they're still available
to watch today.
The episodes make up wait for it the "Bad
Batch" arc, and one installment is essentially
the exact same episode as the Clone Wars season
7 premiere currently streaming on Disney+.
This has led fans to believe that perhaps
some or all of the previously leaked episodes
were completed for inclusion in the Clone
Wars season 7 bundle.
If this is the case, well, the revelation
that Echo is alive is only the start of serious
trouble yet to come.
Star Wars: The Clone Wars season 7 will return
with episode 2, "A Distant Echo", on Friday,
February 28.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.